[موسيقى]
من عينيه سيلتحق بنا نائب رئيس جمعيه
الطقس والمناخ الدكتور عبدالله المس
الدكتور عبد الله مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض اريد السؤال بدايه عن
اب اسباب هذا الهطول الغزير للامطار في
شهر ابريل السعوديه ولدي يعني تقول
التقديرات بانه غير مسبوق منذ اربعين عاما
اسعد الله مساء الجميع هذه نعمه من الله
سبحانه وتعالى اذ ان هذا الموسم الموسم
المطري الذي بدا في اكتوبر عام 22 ومستمر
حتى الان ولن ينتهي باذن الله تعالى الا
بنهايه هذا الشهر شهر مايو هو في الواقع
موسم مطري غزير ونستطيع القول انه
استثنائي سواء على مستوى القيم
والارقام التي تم تسجيلها في المحطات
المطريه او على مستوى ذكريات كبار السن او
حتى على مستوى جريان الاوديه وعلى مستوى
ايضا الربيع الذي انتشر في معظم المناطق
فهو استثنائي وما ذاك الا بسبب ان الله
سبحانه وتعالى
قدر العوامل التي تضافرت سواء كانت من
البوابه الشماليه الغربيه التي تاتي منها
السحب والمخفضات الجويه التي تؤثر على
المملكه العربيه السعوديه او البوابه
الجنوبيه الغربيه التي ايضا تاتي من اواسط
افريقيا ومن بحر العرب ومن ثم
تؤثر على امطار المملكه العربيه السعوديه
فكانت
المثاليه في الاحوال الجويه والعناصر
الجويه منذ دخول ولا كنت موسم الامطار في
اكتوبر الماضي دكتور هل يمكن الجسم بتاثير
برنامج الاستمطار الحالي على هذه الكميه
الغزيره من الامطار
نتائج الاستمطار ان لا يمكن ان
نقول انها ناجحه او غير ذلك من خلال موسم
واحد لذلك استغرب من الاخوه في وزاره
البيئه او المركز الوطني للارصاد ان
اعلنوا النتائج قبل نهايه الموسم الموسم
بقي فيه شهر مايو ومع ذلك اعلان النتائج
ان كانت ايجابيه او سلبيه اتوقع انه يفترض
ان تكون هناك جهه محايده جهه اخرى هي التي
تقوم بتقييم هذا العمل وهذه العمليات
الاستمطار الذي تم في هذا في هذا الموسم
كثير يا دكتور يتحدث عن التغير المناخي
الذي يحدث في العالم سواء بارتفاع درجات
الحراره بانخفاضها بزياده كميه الامطار
ربما بالقحط في اماكن كذلك اخرى هل ما
يحدث من تغير مناخي في العالم له ارتباط
بما يحدث من كميه امطار وهطولها بهذا
الشكل الغزير وهل هو ايجابي اصلا لمنطقتنا
منطقه الخليج العربي
الاحترار العالمي والتغير المناخي امر
ملموس في الواقع ومصور ومسجل وعليه
الاتفاق بغض النظر عن اسباب هذا التغير
فيما يتعلق بارتفاع درجه الحراره والتي
تعاني منه او يعاني منه كوكب الارض فهذا
امر سلبي سواء كان على الحيوان او النبات
او حتى الانسان وايضا حتى الجمادات اما
فيما يتعلق بعنصر الامطار فمن الصعوبه
بمكان ان نقول ان التغير المناخي سيؤثر
ايجابا على كميات الامطار التي سوف تهطل
في المستقبل على المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اذ ان النماذج المناخيه لم تتفق حتى الان
هي لا مستقبل الامطار في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه نظرا لصعوبه
التوقعات في مثل هذا العنصر المطري وان
كانت المؤشرات الاوليه تشير الى حد ما الى
امر ايجابي بارتفاع يقدر بنسبه معينه وهذا
ليس عليه الاتفاق كما ذكرت اشكرك لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات